c'est ensemble que les élus hommes
femmes de la majorité du conseil
départemental on souhaiter leurs voeux
pour la nouvelle année à l'ensemble de
la presse
l'occasion de présenter les enjeux et
les priorités de la nouvelle mandature
moi j'ai deux mandatures qui a été
élaboré l'année dernière s'articule
autour d'un point essentiel l'insertion
des publics en difficulté l'association
professionnelle durable des publics en
difficulté on s'appuie sur les
associations
on veut travailler avec les entreprises
parce que notre projet c'est de dire que
toute personne qui est aujourd'hui en
situation de chômage qui n'arrivent pas
à trouver à s'insérer durablement
eh bien on doit l'accompagner pour que
cette personne retrouve un travail et
réalise son projet personnel
c'est très difficile pour nous nous
n'avons pas des solutions à tout les
problèmes mais on se bat quotidiennement
sur ce créneau
ce qui est important c'est le vivre
ensemble on a des différences sont aussi
des ressemblances
il fallait bien deux côtés ce qui nous
sépare pour mettre en avant tout ce que
nous unit c'est ça c'est ça le voeu que
l'on dossier faire prospérer en 2016 que
l'éducation soit au corps de notre
dispositif que par les politiques nous
culturelles sportives et par
l'association on arrive à faire en sorte
que chacun trouve sa place et
qu'effectivement nevin toutes les sortes
de dérives
une nouvelle mandature qui place le
citoyen au coeur des dispositifs
d'accompagnement du département il
s'agit de favoriser le développement
humain de promouvoir le développement
des territoires et d'innover dans la
construction des parcours d'insertion
rendre dans le domaine économique lorsqu
un jeune arrive avec un projet
s'il y a une plateforme où il peut avoir
tous les renseignements et ben ça va lui
simplifier la vie
parce que figurez-vous content moi j'ai
vu des jeunes qui ont créé leur
entreprise et qui sont arrivés à prendre
des informations au coup par coup et à
chaque fois qu'ils prennent une
information c'est un délit d'attentes de
trois mois et quand on multiplie ses
délais d'attentes
c'est un temps qui est trop long et qui
fait dépenser beaucoup d'argent et qui
fait perdre les moyens et la dynamique à
ce jeune qui a envie de réussir donc
avec cette plateforme il pourra avoir
tous les éléments vraiment faire une
synthèse du travail qui doit faire et
mettre en oeuvre et pour ainsi avancé
dans de bonnes conditions et bien
synthétisé le tout diminuer le temps qui
devra prendre pour régler les différents
problèmes et réaliser son projet à
moindre coût le département devra faire
face à un défi de taille
maintenir un équilibre budgétaire malgré
la diminution des moyens et la baisse
des dotations de l'état
les gars de compensation entre eux nous
mais ceux que nous versons au titre des
allocations de solidarité principalement
le r est simple est ce que l'état nous
rembourse réellement ces deux ans ne
cesse de saint point
bien évidemment nous n'aurons de cesse
de rappeler à l'état que son
désengagement met en péril le bon
fonctionnement des collectivités locales
et plus grave encore la mise en oeuvre
des politiques publiques aux villes des
personnes les plus nécessiteuses
pas question cependant de ne pouvoir
faire face à nos responsabilités nous
chercherons toutes les pistes
d'économies possibles dépenser mieux
faire autrement
optimiser les recettes trouver une
meilleure synergie avec le privé sont
autant d'éléments de notre nouvelle
approche budgétaire
les journalistes de la presse écrite
télé et radio ont répondu présent à ce
rendez vous un moment des changes entre
politiques et les différentes rédactions
du paysage médiatique réunionnais c'est
aussi l'occasion de rencontrer les élus
dans un cadre qui est autre que celui
évidemment beaucoup plus institutionnel
sur lequel le dire qu'une conférence de
presse qu'une séance plénière etc
c'est l'occasion d'échanger sur
différents dossiers d'avoir des
appréciations ou des commentaires comme
on appelle chez nous vous savez en off
sur tel ou tel sujet et puis c'est aussi
un moment convivial cachons pas